validations and transformation this
video is just about keeping a set of
things a set of rules or guidelines in
mind while you are designing your apis
these are mostly related to data
integrity and security that's where
validations and Transformations come
into play so let's understand where
exactly do we use it this we have
already discussed in a typical backend
architecture we have different different
layers of execution so the bottom layer
is mostly called the repository layer
which mostly deals with database
connections and database uh query
executions and insertions deletions and
everything uh related to data it could
be a traditional relational database or
it could be redis or any other kind of
database a some kind of persistent
storage and above that we have our
service layer service layer and this
layer typically deals with executing
your business logic different different
things that you might do in a typical
API execution right so it could be
calling one or two repository methods
and sending a notification to different
different devices and sending an email
to users and storing data and making a
web hook call etc etc service basically
defines all the functionality that an
API call usually has a typical service
method calls one or more methods from
repository layer to interact with the
databases above that we have our we have
controller layers okay and in this layer
uh it calls whatever the method that is
defined in the service layer which
executes all the business logic it calls
the itory methods uh and it sends email
notifications whatever everything that
an API is expected to do and all the
data that the API is expected to return
so all of that responsibility falls upon
the service layer and the controller
layer calls the service layer whatever
method that is associated with that
particular API it calls that method and
whatever data is returned from that
service method is returned to the user
in that HTTP connection the reason we
separate out controller layer and the
service layer is because we want to keep
the HTTP related stuff in a different
layer HTTP related stuff as in uh what
error code to return or what uh success
code to return to the client and what
what format the data is expected to be
returned in that API and what are the
validations that we need to do that
we'll see soon and all this data related
stuff and all the HTTP logic related
stuff we want to separate out into a
different layer that's why we keep the
controller layer it deals with all the
data that comes from clients and all the
data that goes out to the client and
internally it calls the service layer
and service layer internally might call
the repository layer and it might not
depending on the requirements and that's
how a typical API call looks like it it
reaches the controller layer and
controller layer interacts with the
service layer service layer interact
with the repository layer and whatever
data is returned from the service layer
is returned to the user whoever is
making the API call this is a very
simplified execution call now where
exactly do we have validations and
transformation ideally validations and
Transformations happen somewhere here at
this point point the the point where the
data that is sent by the client it is
typically a Json payload and the point
where the data reaches the server which
is the control erer it first it goes to
the route matching algorithm whatever
route is matched it calls the respective
controller method of that route whatever
controller method is assigned to to that
route matching pattern now after the
route is matched and before we start
executing whatever business logic we
have in the controller layer the first
step that we do is the validations and
Transformations at this point at exactly
this point before any significant logic
is run or executed in the controller
layer before calling the service methods
or before executing the business logic
this is where we do validations and
transformations what is the idea behind
validations and transformation why are
we talking about it so imagine this is
our server and we have different
different clients all over the world
different different users and all of
them make API calls they make HTTP
connections and they make API calls to
the server now the idea behind
validations and transformation is
whatever data whatever Json payload
these clients are sending whatever query
parameters whatever query parameters
these clients are sending or whatever
path parameters also any kind of data it
can be Json payload it can be query
parameters it can be path parameters it
can be headers whatever all these kinds
of data before they enter into our
server the first entry point which uh as
you know after the route is matched and
it calls the associated controller
method before before that happens we
want to make sure all this data the Json
the query parameters the path parameters
all these data are in the expected
format they are in the expected format
which means we want to make sure that
whatever data this particular API needs
the user is sending that data in the
exact format that the API expects in
which means let's say it's a Json
payload and we want a field called name
we want to field call named and we have
this requirement for this API we are
expecting one Json payload in the
request body and inside the Json we are
expecting a field called name which is a
string and there could be other
restrictions also we want a string whose
length is between five characters to 100
characters and it we can be as specific
as possible but that's the basic idea
now if if we have an API that has a
requirement like this we want to make
sure that when the data reaches and
before we start executing before we go
into the service layer before we start
calling the database methods we before
we do anything significant we want to
make sure that the structure of the data
is in the exact format that we expect so
when the Json reaches at this entry
point we execute our validation and
transformation pipeline so which is
basically basically a middleware
function or some kind of utility
function that we use that we reuse in
every API and we provided a a particular
schema that we want to validate against
which makes sure it goes through all the
fields of that Json so we are saying we
are expecting field call name so it
checks whether there is a field call
name in that Json payload then it sends
an error right away to the client that
the name field is required which is not
provided in the Json payload in the same
way if the name field is present then it
goes one level deep it checks the value
of the name it checks whether the name
field is a string or not whether we are
sending an array uh in the name field
when the AP is expecting a string then
it checks the type of the data if the
data is string or not if it is string
then it continues if it is not a string
then it sends an error message to the
client that they're expecting a string
but you are sending an error you are
sending a bullion whatever the data the
client is sending out then if that value
of that name field is string then it
goes inside it checks the length of the
field uh the length of the value so our
requirement our the Restriction that we
have put on this field is the length
should be five characters to 100
characters and if the condition does not
satisfy if the client is sending a huge
field if it is sending a whole paragraph
then we immediately send an error that
the length is too long similarly if the
client is sending a two character string
then we also send an error that the
expected length is not matched whatever
the customized error message is now the
whole idea is with this example we just
made sure that this payload this data
structure that this API needs to do
whatever uh database operation it needs
to do to execute what whatever business
logic it uh needs to execute we just
made sure that the data is at least in
the expected format and the reason we do
it at the entry point is because we
don't have any unexpected state or our
system does not break under unexpected
circumstances and by unexpected I mean
let's imagine we did not have this
validation Pipeline and the client sent
this payload we the client sent this
Json
with name as value zero instead of a
string it send the value name as zero
now what happened as in our previous
demo as you know here we are doing
validations let's say we did not do
validations here so the data reached
here the Json with this value name as
zero the data reached here in the
controller layer and since we are not
doing validations the controller layer
in turn call a service layer and It
executes Whatever the business logic is
and the service layer in turn calls a
repository method we are uh creating a
new document we are creating a new row
in the database for some kind of entity
let's say it's a book name so we are
expecting the name of the book and
depending on that we are creating a new
row in the database now because we did
not do validation at the entry point of
our server now what happens is the data
reaches here up to the repository method
and the repository method executes the
database query it's some kind of insert
query and it inserts this name into the
new books table because we are creating
a new book with the name that the user
has provided with now usually in
relational databases we have data type
constraints when we are creating a table
we usually tell the database what the
type of the data is going to be for that
field now when creating the books table
we must have done something like this we
created a column and the name of the
column is name it's a bit confusing but
for the sake of this example the name of
the column is the string name and the
data type for this is let's imagine it's
a postgress uh database we can say the
data type is text and it is not null
okay and since this is the database
level constraint for the data type which
is a expecting a string in the postgress
nomenclature it is expecting a text data
type now since we are inserting a number
data type since the client provided us
with a number value we executed this
insertion operation with the value zero
now what happens the database call fails
of course postgress uh validates all the
data types before doing any kind of
operation and the database called fails
depending on the error handling
situation of the server the client will
get a 500 which means internal server
error which basically says something
went wrong in the server something
unexpected happened in the server now
that is a very poor user experience to
have in a basic form API now this is why
we want to make sure whatever data that
the API needs that the service method
needs we want to make sure at the entry
point that it is of the exact same
structure of the exact same restrictions
that our business logic needs before we
do anything significant with it so that
if the data does not satisfy those
constraints we can send an error code of
400 which means bad request by the
client we can say the data that you have
sent does not satisfy our constraint so
you have to read try with the
appropriate data formats that is the
need of validations to show a simple
example of how validations look like we
have a server running in this address in
Local Host and we are making an API call
this is insomnia we can use this tool to
make API requests and we are making a
post request to this endpoint / API /
valid SL syntactic and in the body we
are sending a empty Json payload now if
we execute this we get this error which
are a set of values in an array it says
it the API is expecting three Fields one
email one phone and one date and all of
them are required and since we are
sending an empty Json payload the API is
throwing as an error right away that
these three fields are required and you
are not providing them now if let's go
ahead and provide these fields so we
write email let's provide some random
string for the email part and then we
have phone the phone also let's do some
number random number and then we have a
date the date let's provide a date let's
say a date 2025
5 01 11 and if we execute this we get
two errors that the email is invalid
invalid email format and in the phone
field it's saying it's expecting a
string but it received a number okay so
let's go ahead and satisfy these
constraints for the email structure we
can just do
test.com let's go ahead and now the
email field is satisfied it just says
for the phone now for the phone let's
make this string and if we run this the
success code is 200 now there are
different types of validations and these
are not strictly the types there could
be of course more number of types
depending on the requirement but
overally these are the three types that
you will encounter most of the times the
first one is syntactic what is syntactic
IC validation in here we have
validations like validating whether a
provided string is an email or not which
means the validation algorithm whatever
depending on the whatever language you
using whatever library that you are
using that validation logic that
validation algorithm will check whether
the provided string satisfies this
particular structure emails have this
particular structure that there is this
initial value
let's say this called First and there is
this character special character which
is at the rate and there is a domain
which typically follows some name
followed by some top level domain which
can be Orco doin anything there are like
thousands of different types of domain
name the email follows a typical
structure like this so This validation
algorithm will check whether this
provider string for follows this
structure or not if it doesn't it throws
an error similarly validating phone
numbers also follow into syntactic
validation because that also has to
follow a particular structure it can be
the country code followed by a 10
digigit number and it can be any country
codes a list of country codes all over
the world and depending on the country
code how many digits follow the country
code those types of valid they fall
under syntactic validation in the same
way we have let's say dates dates also
have a particular structure and they
also fall under syntactic validation
whether a provided string falls into
this structure whatever structure that
AP is expecting let's say it expects in
this format the year then month then day
so whether this string follows this
structure or not these are the some
examples of syntactic validation then we
have semantic validation semantic
validation basically means whether the
provider data makes sense or not for
example let's say we have a form for
data birth in the front end and the user
can provide it the data worth and the
back end will save that in database
through the API call now we want to make
sure that whatever data that user
provides whatever date the user provides
it makes sense in a semantic way which
means user cannot provide a date which
is in the future let's say today's date
is
2025 and if the user provides a date is
like
2025 which does not make sense right
your date of birth cannot be in future
so validating these kinds of patterns in
data falls under semantic validation we
want to make sure that the data
whatever the data is provided by the
user makes sense in a semantic way in
the same way if we have a field called
age which takes the age of the user and
if the user provides an age let's say
called 365 so our validation pipeline
should reject this because an age 365
does not make sense at least not yet it
might in the future but as of now this a
does not make sense in a semantic way so
these kinds of validations follow under
semantic validation now the third type
is type validation type validation is
our basic validation of validating
whether the data type match or not so
whether the particular field is a string
or not whether it is a number or it is a
bullion or it is an array or a custom
Json payload and that Json can have
other primary data types like string
number bullion array etc etc so these
kinds of validations are called type
validation so overall these are the
different different kinds of validation
that you will encounter uh while you are
designing apis and as I said these are
not things that you should that you need
to understand or you need to remember
these are the things that you just have
to keep in your mind while you're
designing your apis like how strict you
want to be with your data
and how strict you want to be with your
validation Pipeline and how specific you
want to be and since the title of the
video also contains the term
transformation let's talk about
transformation now as I said before
reaching before reaching our controller
layer whatever data that is coming from
the user needs to go through this
pipeline is called the validation and
transformation pipeline now validation
we have already understood which
basically means uh confirming whatever
data that the a is expecting the user
data satisfies that structure and
validations can be as specific as
possible and as lose as possible
depending on the requirement now that is
validation now transformation means we
want to execute some operations on the
data that is provided by the user
depending on the success or failure of
the validation pipeline or any other
default executions now that is a little
complicated to get our heads around so
let's see an example so in a typical
pated API we send different different
query parameters in the API in the query
string so we have this API the end point
is let's say slash bookmarks is slash
bookmarks and we want to send parameters
these ones page as two and limit as
let's say 20 these are called query
parameters and since in the start of the
video we talked about we should validate
everything that is coming from the
client before it reaches our service
layer before we execute any significant
logic now we have to validate our query
parameters so this is how we can Define
our validation logic we want to say that
page is a field uh which will be coming
in the query parameter which is a number
which is a number which should be
greater than zero and smaller than
depending on your requirement let's say
for in this case it can be should be
smaller than 500 same way limit limit
can should be uh greater than zero and
it should be smaller than say 10,000 at
a time only 10,000 data can be returned
from the server these are our
requirements now coming back we are
saying page is a number which has to
satisfy this constraint same way limit
is a number which has to satisfy this
constant but we already know that page
and limit are query parameters and all
the query parameters are strings by
default when they reach our server from
the users browser or from any client
they are strings back by default because
query parameter all the values in the
query parameters are strings they don't
have any other data type by default they
can satisfy the structure of any other
data type but their value will always be
string when they reach our server in
this case what happens this is how we
receive our data receive page as the
string to and limit as the string 20
from this now because of our validation
requirements this fails this fails
because we are seeing we are expecting a
number the first requirement is it
should be number then we check the value
whether it is greater than zero whether
it is smaller than 500 etc etc but it
fails on the first requirement because
it is a string and the API fails and the
user will get an error that page should
be a string uh page should be a number
but we are receiving a string something
like that depending on your error
message syntax now in this case there
was no error from the client because it
is a query parameter of course all the
fields all the values of the fields will
be in string format by default it is the
server responsibility to transform this
data into a into our expected type you
can also say it is the service
responsibility to cast the data type
cast basically means forcing one data
type to get converted into another data
type so in this example we we have to
cast a string data type into a number
and then we can execute our validation
requirements so this phase is called a
transformation because the data that we
are getting from the client has to go
through some kind of changes before we
can execute our validations it can be
other way also after validation we can
execute some operations to transform
that data into a structure which is
expected by the server okay so this
process of converting data into a
desirable format is called
transformation and usually we pair
validations and transformation in a
single pipeline so that the data layer
the input data layer all the logic in
the input data layer stays in the same
place and we don't have to look in
different different places to find out
what all the requirements are and what
are the operations that we are executing
on the data before doing any business
logic all the requirements of our
validations and all the operations that
we are doing through transformation
stays in one place which is called the
validation and transformation pipeline
now let's look at a few apis to get the
idea of different different flavors of
validations and transformation that we
just talked about we have already seen
the syntactic validation in the demo
that we saw earlier in this video we
executed this API with different
different values and we got errors and
we kept fixing those errors and we got a
successful response of 200 basically we
had to provide a string which satisfies
an email structure we had to provide a
phone number and we had to provide a
date which has this this structure a
valid date structure and after that the
API was successful and this is an
example of syntactic validation because
we had to stick to particular structures
of data it was email phone and date in
this case it can be different different
other kinds of data in the same way
let's see what is semantic validations
so let's execute this so we are getting
this validation error and validations
also have this uh advantage that even if
the client hits this API without any
value they can get some kind of
documentation with the errors that these
are the fields that are expected in this
API which the client is not providing so
that is a very nice way of figuring it
out if the API documentation is not
available in the false place the error
messages the validations error messages
are a very nice way to figure out what
are the expected fields and what are the
expected values in those fields that the
API is demanding from you okay in this
case we sent an empty payload and we got
these errors so the API is expecting two
Fields one as date of birth which says
is required and the second one is age it
says expected number is none okay now
let's provide these values to this API
so the first field is date of worth and
for this let's provide a date
1995 the month is June and some random
date is 12 let's execute this and the
date of birth was satisfied and now it
says age is required so let's also
provide an age age is let's say 43 and
when we send this the API is successful
and we are getting the same value that
we have sent now since this demo is
about semantic validation let's change
these values instead of
1995 let's make it the year
2026 as the date of birth and send this
now we get this error that date of birth
cannot be in the future this is what uh
we had talked about earlier the semantic
validation checks that whether the value
of a field makes sense or not in a
semantic way since the date of birth of
a person cannot be in the future we are
throwing this error for this field that
date of birth cannot be in the future in
the same way let's revert this and let's
make the age 430 instead instead of 43
let's make it 430 and then we get this
that number must be less than or equal
to 120 logical age for a person at this
times is from 1 to to 120 even though a
oneyear old uh won't be hitting our APA
but still they're accepting ages from 1
to1 that's why it's called semantic
validation we are checking whether the
values provided in different different
fields make sense in a semantic way or
not okay in this one let's hit this this
API is expecting three Fields one
password another is password
confirmation and the third one is
married or not okay now let's provide
these values password system called
random and passord
information another string and for merit
mared say false and this let's hit this
now this is another kind of validation
check that we usually do so in most of
the platforms we have a password fi and
a confirm password field just for
security regions and to check the
Integrity of the data whether the user
uh has provided valid data or not so the
requirement is always that the password
confirmation value should always match
the password value right and since we
are sending different different strings
in these two Fields that's why the API
is returning the error that passwords
don't match for this field password
confirmation for the password field it
is returning an error that string must
contain at least eight characters that
is the requirement of the password now
let's fix this to satisfy the
constraints we have six characters let's
add one more and let's copy this and
paste this here so that these two Fields
match and when we run this now it is
true the IP is successful now what
happens if we do m as true run this we
get another error that the API is
expecting another field called partner
if the field married is true it says
partner name is required when married is
true so if we provide the value is true
we also have to provide a name in the
field partner because the user saying it
is married let's provide another field
just called partner and some let run
this and we get a successful response
with all the fields that we have
provided and in this particular example
it is called complex because uh
depending on the requirements of the
service layer we can Define our
validation constraints in the first one
we are saying that two Fields should
have the same value that's what this
constraint was about in the second one
we are seeing the partner field is
optional when married is false but if
the married field is true
the user also have to provide another
field called partner with the name of
the partner so we can also do these
complex pipelines inside our validation
pipeline when dealing with users data
okay now moving on to our transformation
example let's run this and it says email
phone date it requires three Fields so
let's provide three Fields let's just
copy this one from our earlier demo and
and write it here let me send this okay
and in order to see how the
transformation Works in this particular
API let's make this email change the
cases of this email let's
see a and in the and then when we run
this we are getting this value now what
I want to show here is the user is
sending data in an unexpected format in
a particular structure the structure is
of an email but inside that it has lower
case and it has upper case and in the
phone number also it is it does not
provide the character plus before the
phone number and and the date it
provides this particular date structure
and when we send this to server the
server does some transformation it
changes the data according to the
requirements of the service layer and
because of that even though we sent the
value of the email with different
different cases lower case and upper
case when we got the value back it was
in all lower case because the server in
the validation pipeline it transformed
the value into lower case before doing
any kind of executions on the data now
that's the reason we got this email
which is in all lower case in the same
way for the phone field whatever value
we sent in this field it added this
character plus before the value and it
sent it back to us same with the field
it calculated in a different format and
send it back this is some example of
transformation uh after the client send
some data in the payload the server can
do some kind of operations on the data
to transform it into a different format
for the convenience of the service layer
or for the requirements of the service
layer before performing any kind of
executions on it in the same way let's
run the example of type validations and
when you run this we get
we the IPA is expecting four Fields one
is string field one is number field one
is arror field and one is Will so let's
first provide all these uh values then
we'll see what are the validation errors
first one let's say string field string
field and the string is something and
let's just copy this and paste it this
is a number field and this is an array
field and this is a bullan field and
let's hit this API now this error is
gone now the number field is saying
expected number received string the
array field is saying expected array
received string same for the bullan
field now this is an example of type
validation that's why because we're
showing a demo of how the server can
enforce different different data types
from the client so in order to fix these
errors we make this some valid number
let's say 10 and when you hit this that
is gone we have an array and bullan
errors this we can send an error we can
send an array with value one and two and
for the Boolean field we can send false
and now when we run this we are getting
more errors which says inside the array
field the element zero it is expected to
be a string but we are sending numbers
now to fix this let's make this strings
string now when we run this we are
getting all the values that we had
provided the string field has string
value the number field has number value
the array field has array value but for
each element of the array we can also
enforce different validation constants
which in this case was each element
should be of type string and in the last
one it is a bullan type okay either true
or false and the last thing that I want
to bring into attention is this concept
sometimes there are confusions and
people sometimes do this mistake of
replacing front end validation with
backend validation okay this mistake
happens because usually in a typical
platform we have forms and inside forms
we do some kind of validation for
example let's say we have this form we
have this form and there is a field
called name and it's an input box and
the user has to type some name
and if it's valid if the name satisfies
whatever requirements that we have
either the minimum or maximum number of
characters or the data type matching
whatever else it is if it is successful
then when the user clicks on the submit
button we call the AP if the validation
is not successful we show some errors in
the form itself that this data type is
does not satisfy our constraints and
when it does satisfy the constraints we
call the AP and the back end does
whatever stuff that it needs to do right
now the thing to keep in mind is for all
interactions for all apis we need both
the front end validation and the server
side validation our backend validation
because front end validation the reason
we use frontend validation is for ux
which means user experience frontend
validation is not for security or data
Integrity it is for user experience we
want to give some immediate feedback to
the user that something is wrong with
the data and the data that we are
expecting does not match the data that
you have provided it is not about
security backend validation which we do
that is for security and data integrity
that's the reason it does not matter
what kind of validations your front end
does whether it does or whether it
doesn't because a typical server can
have different different clients it can
have a uh very convenient web app which
can do different different types of
validation but as we saw it can also
have a API client based interface for
example something like Postman or
something like insomnia right there
there is no concept of validation right
because we are directly interacting with
our apis there is no front-end interface
that acts as a proxy to our API which
acts as a user interface right in that
case there is no front- end validation
at all so if the backend depends on the
front end validation for security
purpose or for the data Integrity
purpose our server will break when the
client changes that's why this is a very
important concept when we are talking
about validation and transformation it
does not matter what the client is when
you're designing your apis you have to
be as strict and as specific as possible
in your server side validation logic
without thinking of what the client
validation will look like because as I
said client validation is for the user
experience but server validation is for
security and data Integrity now for all
the API examples that we saw earlier in
the API client insomnia we also have a
we also have a complimentary front end
interface to deal with those apis for
all the different different types
syntactic semantic type uh
transformation and complex now let's see
how front end and backend validations
work together now inside this let's
provide some email let's say some email
let's provide wrong values first then we
can see whether it works or not the
phone number also let's provide some 1 2
3 4 5 and date we already have a date
set Lector so we can choose any date now
let's do submit in this case we did not
make any API calls yet because the front
end detected that there is something
wrong with this field and it is a front
end side validation it is the client
side validation now to satisfy this we
have to make this a proper email we can
WR this
gmail.com and then when we do submit we
do a proper API call and when we see the
payload it is sending the this and in
the preview it is getting this and it is
a getting a 200 response is a success
response this is how client side
validation and server side validation
work together the client side validation
provides a proper user experience
provides immediate feedback to the
client to the user and the server side
validation performs different different
Security checks and it is a mandatory
validation which has the purpose of
security and data Integrity but the
front endend validation has the purpose
of user experience and providing
immediate feedbacks now that's pretty
much all there is to talk about
validations and transformation it's not
a very complex topic or a very large
topic just a set of rules and guidelines
to follow when you are designing your
apas